mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren nachdem ich ja bereits auf die
germany's next topmodel 2009 10
kandidatinnen reagiert habe ihr ex
freund hat ihr vorgeschrieben wie viele
täler sie essen schlafen
nachdem ich auf die diesjährigen
kandidatinnen bereits reagiert habe
reagieren wir heute auf das gntm um das
msn vertauscht so blöd aussehen
wir schauen uns heute allerdings nicht
die komplette folge an die auch im tv
lief vor zwei tagen habe ich euch unten
in der beschreibung verlegen wenn ihr
euch die komplett anschauen wollt könnt
ihr das sehr gern machen sondern wir
sind hier auf der website denn es gibt
hier so eine tolle funktion da sieht man
wie die vorher aussah das ist die tat
jana hier zum beispiel die tatjana war
vorher so aus die schaut echt leicht
bekifft hat ja auf jeden fall haben wir
eine supercoole funktion und zwar sehen
wir hier gerade wie sie vor dem
umstyling aussah und jetzt können wir
auf nachher klicken und
da ist dass das doch ein anderer mensch
so sah die tatjana vorher aus und jetzt
sieht sie so aus normalerweise macht das
umstyling die models irgendwie immer ein
bisschen komisch aber in dem fall
respekt hat ja das sieht echt nicht so
kacke aus ich weiß nicht was passiert
wenn man hier auf look 1
[Musik]
ich glaube dass hatten die tatsächlich
auch in der folge ich habe die
umstellung folge vorgestern zusammen mit
julia im fernsehen geschaut und da
hatten die nämlich auch dieses tool das
sich die models die bisherigen
kandidatinnen halt hier durch diese
looks an durchscrollen konnten und das
sind deutlich die echten haare sondern
so animierte haare und dann konnten ja
gucken wie das aussieht ich habe in
meiner instagram story auch schon so ein
bisschen auf das umstyling reagiert jung
ist sie im werkzeugkasten gefallen dass
sie so eine alge ihr solltet ihr
unbedingt auf instagram mal folgen
allerdings sieht so die liebe tatiana
aus und ich würde sagen wir machen
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
kandidaten das ist jetzt ist ja gerade
alles verrutscht wieder das ist die
liebe theresia dieser vorher so aus am
ist er ideal mich die mit diesem
komischen kleinen stofftier ja die hat
in jeder folge irgendwie hatte ihr
kleines stofftier namens herbert mit
dabei auf jeden fall sei die theresia
vorher so aus ein kleines unschuldiges
mädchen wenn man jetzt hier auf nachher
also kein scheiß die beiden bisherigen
models die wurden ja echt m
ja
hätte ich nicht gemacht dass auch nicht
und da
wie die sie gemacht haben als sie sie
aus wie taylor swift so ein bisschen
machen wir allerdings direkt weiter mit
der nächsten kandidaten und zwar der
lieben vanessa ich klicke hier einfach
auch direkt auf nachher so sah sie
vorher aus und
dr
muss man sagen die wurden echt
verbessert also so sah die vanessa
vorher aus umringt und nachher saadi
vanessa so aus also ich meine ich find
rothaarig jetzt nicht so schön
eigentlich bei frauen aber ihr stets
wirklich respekt man deshalb als
nächstes machen wir weiter mit der
simone müssen sie hier von ihr habe ich
tatsächlich bisher noch gar nichts
mitbekommen auch als
ist auch besser geworden
also wenn ich
ich denke dann denke ich halt immer nur
ein letztes jahr und dann dieser sei ja
war nicht so schön aber das hier
wirklich bei der simone also hier so sah
sie vorher aus und so nachher der kader
hat sich bei der simone tatsächlich
jetzt nicht so viel verändert aber
bisher finde ich ist wirklich bei jedem
mädel das nachher bild besser als es
vorher bild und das ist ja schon mal ein
fortschritt dass hier ist die star jana
naja das war ein richtiger löwen name
finde ich so sah sie auf jeden fall vor
dem umstyling aus und nach dem umstyling
was haben sie gemacht alter ire
hätte mehr ist da irgendwie nicht
passiert log einst sehr so aus bei der
zwei jahre look zwei sehe so aus und luk
drei so ganz im ernst dass das legt sich
das beste also haben sie auch verbessert
die sarah hier ist die nächste ist sie
einfach viel kleiner als die anderen
wenn ich hier so
bis hier bei der sache habe ich vor ein
paar tagen so ein video in den trends
gesehen dass sie wohl anscheinend um die
schlange diesmal ist also keine ahnung
ich hab das ja nur das umstyling so ein
bisschen geguckt aber anscheinend gibt
es viele leute die gegen sie sind aber
darum soll es heute nicht geben wir
gehen ja nicht auf die folge sondern auf
das umstyling im vorjahr sie so aus und
nachher sieht sie so aus
ich glaube die haben die haare gefärbt
und vor die schultern gehängt weil so
viele veränderungen sicht als auch nich
look 1c so aus bei der sarah i das passt
überhaupt nicht die haben ja auch zwei
andere farben einmal pink und einmal
sonne rot also das passt überhaupt nicht
luck 2 passt gingen noch und luk 3 sieht
so aus passt auch gar nicht also ich
find bei der sarah hat sich auf jeden
fall auch verbessert die sache hat
allerdings von allen bisher die
wenigsten likes was auch immer die lecks
zu bringen das hier ist die minister die
hat einen sehr ausgefallenen stil hat
ihm ein tier selbst ist die diesjährige
staffel von gntm aufgebautes auf dem
thema diversity glaubt vor einigen
jahren hätte sie nicht so ganz in diesem
model schiene reingepasst allerdings
dieses jahr passt es schon ganz gut ihm
das auf jeden fall das vorher foto und
nachher sieht es
ich sehe keine veränderung ich weiß
nicht ob ich blind bin aber ich sehe
keine veränderungen wir machen direkt
weiter mit der lieben luna luna ist und
richtiger name für sonne mond name für
einen montag wir haben ja auch so viele
monde so sah die luna auf jeden fall
vorher aus wenn wir auf nachher klicken
das erste mal
dass ich sage ich finde das hier besser
dieses zerzauste und auch dass sie hier
so nun im unterhemd steht ich finde es
passt da passen die haare besser als das
es ist auch nicht schlecht aus aber ich
glaube ich verstehe was meinen dass
jetzt die leoni
sie war vorher so aus also auch so ein
bisschen eine wellige haare ähnlich wie
die luna gerade nachher sieht diese
krank kranke veränderungen ich glaube
die hat extensions bekommen heißt es
extension keine ahnung von irgendwas
vorher sah sie so aus und nachher sieht
sie so aus also das haben die kranken
gegrillt als ich mir vorgestern das
umstyling mit julia angeschaut habe habe
ich mir extra nicht die endergebnisse
nachher angeschaut sondern nur wie die
halt geheult haben unseren schwachsinn
aber das hier also bisher von allen
leuten hier ist leonel so der krasseste
schritt alter das ist heftig aber mein
gott okay das geht gar nicht wir machen
als nächstes weiter mit der lieben lena
m sie hatte ja vorher diese roten haare
die hat mich so ein bisschen an jesse
von team rocket erinnert
so sah die lena auf jeden fall vorher
aus und nach dem umstyling sie
was ist los dieses jahr dieses jahr gntm
umstyling ist von so bei der lena nach
so ich sage euch vor einigen jahren wäre
es doch so gewesen dass die vorher so
aussah und die die beim umstyling so
gemacht haben mit ihnen einem dummen
grund von wegen hellrot mach deine
blauen augen viel bunter dann machen wir
es nicht weiter mit der justin hier
vorne vorhang das ist auf jeden fall
vorher und nachher sieht
ich
ich glaube ihr blick verrät
von heldt ich bin eigentlich ziemlich
zufrieden mit meinen haaren
ach du scheiße was ist denn hier
passiert julia ist die nächste
kandidatin hier dieser vorher so aus ein
ganz normales hübsches süßes mädchen
würde ich sagen deswegen bin ich sehr
gespannt was sie da gemacht dann
wahrscheinlich auf die haare
abgeschnitten länger gemacht da sieht
man wie viel ahnung ich hab machen wir
nun weiter mit der lieben jasmin bei der
jasmin habe ich mit bekommen in der
folge dass sie keine freunde so wirklich
hat bei gntm also sie musste auf dem
sofa schlafen weil keiner mit ihrem bett
schlafen wollte also ich bin gespannt
was mit ihnen passiert ist vorher sie so
aus und nachher sieht
krass at abgesehen vom charakter und ob
man die marke oder ob sie komisch ist
oder keine ahnung woher sah es echt
ziemlich ziemlich zerzaust aus und jetzt
alter das ist echt ein bisschen boßler
also bei der jasmin hat sich auf jeden
fall auch kassels positiven verändert
finde ich machen wir nun weiter mit der
freundin von simon desue ja sehe ich
auch keine große veränderung ausser dass
der extensions drin sind wir allerdings
zur nächsten kandidatin uns bei der
lieben caroline m sie sah so aus vorher
finde ich ist ein ordentlicher stil also
ein unschuldiges mädchen und nachher
sieht sie so aus
sich nichts getan die cäcilia vorher so
aus und nach dem umstyling keine
veränderung und das letzte model aus der
diesjährigen staffel gntm sah vor dem
umstyling so aus wie alicia und nach dem
umstyling so
allerdings finde ich wirklich die
krasseste veränderungen beim
diesjährigen umstyling ist festzustellen
bei der leoni die vorher so aussah und
nachher jetzt so aussieht dann noch bei
der lena die vorher so aussah und
nachher sobald ein komplett neuer stil
ist und bei der jasmin egal was man von
ihr halten mag vorher sah sie so aus und
nachher so das ist eine krasse
veränderung an der stelle durch das
heutige video jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde irgendwann
bricht dieser tisch wenn euch meine
reaktion auf das diesjährige umstyling
von germany's next topmodel 2009 10
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich sehr
sehr dollar bei einem daumen hoch von
euch freund schreiben wir bitten und in
die kommentare ob ich auch dieses jahr
wieder zum gntm finale fahren soll und
dort ein bisschen glocken soll der
zuschauer saß ja allein eine stunden
oder für das heidi sagt wer die scheiße
gewonnen hat
[Applaus]
ja last night da schreibt kommentare und
jetzt kommts outro
[Musik]